that's a lot to unpack get ready to
unpack
this because hannah brown was just
photographed
cozying up to adam willard we will
discuss it later
yep the former bachelorette was spotted
holding hands with the model on saturday
during a walk down abbot kinney
boulevard in venice california
okay so you can't get a great look at
adam's face with that mask on
but he's a very very hunky model
and bachelor nation was quick to point
out that he actually
kinda sorta resembles hannah's runner-up
tyler cameron
exactly anyway oh my gosh
i'm about to go on my first date back in
november hannah revealed that she had
signed up for a dating app
and was stepping back into the dating
scene for the first time since the
bachelorette
i'm just putting myself out there i'm
like you know what this is the time
to have some good old mask fun
there's no pressure for anything because
of
the world that we live in right now i
mean i'm not gonna just like freaking
start
macking on you i don't know you so it
just kind of like gives that good
boundary i think that i'm in full
support of right now in my life
her 2019 season of the abc dating show
ended with a failed engagement to jed
wyatt
after she discovered he had a girlfriend
while he was on the show
the reason i held back details that i
did was because
i was scared that if i told you you'd
walk away from me then she asked out
tyler
they spent the night together but things
quickly fizzled out
we care about each other we're there for
each other and like
i think it's like i'm super stoked where
we're at right now then in december
hannah teased fans about the mystery man
in her life
sharing this pic of her most recent date
on her insta story with a very large
strategically placed emoji over his face
i'm pretty proud of myself well it's
safe to say the case is closed and the
mystery solved
you